aurait presque pu l'oublier le spectre
d'une nouvelle vague ressurgit à l'issue
du conseil des ministres le porte-parole
du gouvernement desbriel atallah parler
d'embellie sur le front de la situation
sanitaire tout en rappelant les menaces
que constituait le variant delta
identifié pour la première fois en inde
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite monnaie à moudre et l'or en
direct de la place beauvau soir mona
gabriela talent qui s'est donc exprimé
aujourd'hui et qui réagit tu le chiffon
rouge
mais exactement disons que c'est un
point presse qui reflète qui refroidit
après la fin du couvre-feu la fin du
masque les français semblent être
rattrapés par la réalité justement lors
de ce point presse traditionnelle à
gabriel attal a clairement indiqué que
ce variant doit nous préoccuper car il
est plus contagieux que les que
l'anglais l exécutif appelle donc à ne
pas baisser la garde d'ailleurs ils
représentent 70% des contaminations dans
les landes écoutez le sur le plan
sanitaire l'embellie se confirme au
niveau national jour après jour et le
retour à une vie normale se poursuit
ensuite il ya l'alertent qui est liée
aux variants bel temps vous savez ce
variant initialement détecté en inde est
considérée comme plus contagieux de
l'ordre de 60% par rapport à la souche
dit britannique qui était elle-même plus
contagieuse de 50% par rapport à la
souche initial les autorités sanitaires
internationales alerte sur ce point et
bona que représente au juste ce variant
en france
et bien selon gabriel attali il
représente pour l'instant 9 à 10% des
contaminations les autorités
internationales et bien elles sont en
alerte et ce qui est inquiétant c'est
que les chiffres changent assez
rapidement puisque la semaine dernière
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
évoqué une fourchette entre 2 à 4 % donc
vous voyez ça va très vite très
rapidement ronald à la reprise de
l'épidémie et tel donc possible si on
vous suit eh bien on croit le
porte-parole du gouvernement c'est une
possibilité car il représente une menace
et il n'est pas le seul à le souligner
puisque des chercheurs des médecins et
sim également que c'est une possibilité
alors pour l'instant parler d'une
quatrième vague serait un peu précoce
mais il faut rester vigilant et on l'a
vu dans le passé l'épidémie nous a
réservé bien des surprises
selon les professionnels et bien là vix
la vaccination serait un des moyens de
freiner l'épidémie et mona quelles
solutions dont pour éviter cette
quatrième vague dont personne évidemment
on a envie
et bien pour l'instant stéphanie pour
contrecarrer une potentielle reprise de
l'épidémie gabriel atallah a indiqué
qu'il fallait protéger les frontières à
l'heure où la france ne vit plus sous le
régime des couvre-feux l'exécutif vient
redoute un relâchement général on l'a vu
d'ailleurs à lors de la fête de la
musique le 21 juin
ou encore il ya à la finale de l'euro
qui inquiète également puisque plus de
soixante mille personnes sont attendues
dans les gradins en israël qu'on pensait
sorti d'affaires il ya eu la découverte
de deux kloster ovarian delta les
autorités ont réintroduit le port du
masque dans certains endroits
alors la france ceux des confine à
l'heure où certains prennent très au
sérieux
ce variant delta la rentrée risque
d'être plus compliqué que prévu
merci mona à mode et l'or et se marier